[Music]
near a great forest dwelt a poor
woodcutter of his wife and his two
children the boy was called Hansel and
the girl Gretel he had little to bite
ten to break and when the great scarcity
fell on the land he could no longer
procure daily bread now when he thought
over this at night in his bed and tossed
about in his anxiety he groaned and said
to his wife what is to become of us how
are we to feed our poor children when we
no longer have anything even for
ourselves I'll tell you what husband
answered the woman early tomorrow
morning we shall take the children into
the forest where it is the thickest
there we will light a fire for them and
give them each one piece of bread and
then we will go to work and leave them
alone they will not find their way home
again and we shall be done with them no
wife said the man how can I here to
leave my children alone in the forest
the wild animals would soon come and
tear them to pieces
oh you fool she said then we must all
four die of hunger you may as well plain
the planks to our coffins now and she
left him no peace until he consented but
I feel very sorry for the poor children
all the same said the man the two
children had also not been able to sleep
for hunger and had heard what their
stepmother had said to their father
Gretel wept bitter tears and said to
Hansel now all is over for us
hush Gretel said Hansel do not distress
yourself I will soon find a way to help
us and when the old folks had fallen
asleep he got up and put on his little
coat opened the door below and crept
outside and the moon shone brightly and
the white pebbles which lay in front of
the house glistened like real silver
pennies Hansel stooped and put as many
of them in his little pocket as he could
then he went back and said to Gretel be
comforted dear little sister and sleep
in peace God will not forsake us
and he lay down again in his bed when
the day dawned but before the Sun had
risen the woman came in a woke the two
children
get up you sluggards will go into the
forest to fetch some wood
she gave each of them a little piece of
bread there is something for your dinner
but do not eat it before 4:00 you'll get
nothing else
Gretel took the bread under her apron as
Hansel still had the stones in his
pocket then they all set out together on
the way to the forest when they had
walked a short time Hansel Stood Still
one peeped back at the house and did so
again and again his father said Hansel
what are you looking at there and
staying behind for mind yourself and do
not forget to use your legs father said
Hansel I'm looking at my little white
cat which is sitting on the roof and
wants to say goodbye to me the wife
turned fool that is not your little cat
that is the Morning Sun shining on the
chimneys Hansel however had not been
looking back at his cats but had been
constantly throwing one of the white
pebbles out of his pocket and onto the
road when they had reached the middle of
the forest to the farthest end now
children pile up some wood and I will
light a fire for you so you may not be
called Hansel and Gretel gathered the
brushwood together as high as a little
hill the brushwood was lit and when the
flames were burnin very high the woman
said now children lay yourselves down by
the fire and rest we will go into the
forest and cut some wood when we had
done we will come back and fetch you
away Hansel and Gretel sat by the fire
and when no one came each ate a little
piece of bread and as they heard the
strokes of the wood axe they believed
that their father was near it was not
however the axe it was a branch which
had been fastened to a withered tree
which the wind was blowing backwards and
forwards and as they had been sitting
for such a long time their eyes shot to
a fatigue and they fell fast asleep when
at last they awoke it was already dark
night Gretel began to cry
said how are we to get out of the forest
now but Hansel comforted his sister and
sent just wait a little until the moon
has risen and then we will soon find the
way and when the full moon had risen
Hansel took his little sister by the
hand and followed the pebbles which
shone like newly coined silver pieces
and showed them the way they walked the
whole night long and by break of day
they once more came to their father's
house they knocked at the door and when
the woman opened it and saw it was
Hansel and Gretel she said you naughty
children
why have you slept so long in the forest
we thought you were never coming back at
all the father however rejoiced for it
had to cut him to the heart to leave
them behind alone not long afterwards
there was another great scarcity and the
children heard their mother at night say
to their father everything is eaten
again we have one half loaf left and
then there is no more the children must
go we will take them farther into the
wood so that they will never find their
way out again there is no other means of
saving ourselves the man's heart was
heavy and he thought to himself it would
be better for you to share your last
mouthful of your children the woman
however would listen to nothing he had
to say but scolded and reproached him he
who says a must say be likewise and as
he had yielded for the first time he had
to do so for a second time also the
children however was still awake and had
heard the entire conversation when the
old folks had fallen asleep again Hansel
again got up and wanted to go outside to
pick pebbles as he did before but the
woman had locked the door and Hansel
could not get out nevertheless he
comforted his sister and said do not cry
Gretel go to sleep quietly and the good
God will help us early in the morning
came the woman and took the children out
of their bed there bit of bread was
given to them but it was so much smaller
than a time before on the way into the
forest Hansel crumbled he's in his
pocket and often stood and threw a
morsel onto the ground
Hansol why do you stop and look around
said the father go on I am looking back
at My Little Pigeon which is sitting on
the roof and wishes to say goodbye to me
answered Hansel simpleton said the woman
and that is not your Little Pigeon that
is the Morning Sun that is shining on
the chimney a Hansel however little by
little through all of the crumbs onto
the path the woman led the children
still deeper into the forest where they
had never in their lives been before
then a great fire was again made and the
mother said
just sit here you children and when you
are tired you may sleep a little we are
going into the forest to cut wood and in
the evening when we are done we will
return to fetch you away when it was
noon Gretel shared a piece of her bread
of Hansel who had scattered he's by the
way the Nathan asleep and the evening
came and went but no one came for the
pond children they did not wake until it
was dark night and Hansel comforted his
sister and said just wait Gretel until
the moon rises and then we shall see the
crumbs of bread which I had strewn about
they will show us the way home again
when the moon came and they set out they
found no crumbs for the many thousands
of birds which fly about in the woods in
the fields had eaten them all Hansel
said to Gretel we shall soon find the
way but they did not find it they walked
the whole night and the next day from
morning to the evening but they did not
get out of the forest and were very
hungry for they had nothing to eat but
two or three berries which had grown on
the ground and as they were so weary
that their legs would carry them no
longer they lay down beneath a tree and
fell asleep it was three mornings since
they had left their father's house they
began to walk again but they always got
deeper into the forest and if help did
not come soon they would die of hunger
and weariness when it was midday they
saw a beautiful snow-white bird sitting
on a bough which sang so delightfully
that they stood still and listened to it
and when it had finished its song it
spread its wings and flew away before
them they followed the bird until they
reached a little house when they came
closer to the little house they saw that
it was made of bread and covered in cake
and the windows were made of clear sugar
we were set to work on that said Hansel
and have a good meal I will eat a piece
of the roof I knew Gretel you can eat
some of the window it should taste sweet
Hansel reached above and broke off a
little piece of the roof to see how it
tasted and Gretel leaned against the
window and nibbled at the panes then a
soft voice cried from the room
nibble nibble gnaw who is nibbling at my
little house the children answered the
wind the wind the heaven-born wind and
they went on eating without disturbing
themselves Hansel who thought the roof
tasted very nice tore down a great piece
of it and Gretel pushed out the hole of
one round windowpane sat down and
enjoyed herself suddenly the door opened
and a very very old woman who supported
herself on crutches came creepin out
Hansel and Gretel was so terribly
frightened that they let for what they
had in their hands
the old woman however nodded her head
and said oh you dear children who has
brought you here do come in and stay
with me no harm shall happen to you she
took them both by the hand and led them
into her little house then good food was
laid before them milk and pancakes with
sugar apples and nuts
afterwards two pretty little beds were
covered with white linen and Hansel and
Gretel laid down in them and thought
they were in heaven the old woman had
only pretended to be so kind she was in
reality a wicked witch who lay in wait
for children and had only built the
little house of bread to entice them
there when a child fell into her power
she killed it cooked and ate it and that
was a feast day to her witches have red
eyes and cannot see far but they have a
keen scent like a beast and are aware of
human beings that draw near when Hansel
and Gretel came into the neighborhood
she laughs maliciously and said
mockingly I have them they will not
escape me again early in the morning
before the children were awake
she was already up and when she saw them
both sleeping looking so pretty with
their plump her cheeks she muttered to
herself that will be a dainty mouthful
then she seized Hansel with her
shriveled hand carried him into a little
stable and shot him in with a grated
door
he might scream as he liked but there
was no use then she went to Gretel shook
her until she awoke and cried get up you
lazy thing fetch some water and cook
something for your brother he is in the
stable outside and is to be made fat
when he is fat I will eat him Gretel
began to weep bitterly but it was all in
vain she was forced to do as the wicked
witch had ordered her and now the best
food was cooked for poor hansel and
gretel got nothing but crab shells every
morning the woman crept up to the stable
and cried Hansel stretch out your finger
that I may feel if you were soon be fat
Hansel however stretched out a little
chicken bone and the old woman who had
demise could not see it and thought it
was Hansel's finger and was astonished
that there was no way of fattening him
when four weeks had gone by and Hansel
still stayed thin she was seized with
impatience and could wait no longer
now Gretel she cried be active and bring
some water
let Hansel be fat or lean tomorrow I
will kill him and cook him and how the
poor little sister did lament when she
had to fetch the water dear God to help
us she cried if the wild beasts in the
forest had devoured us at least we would
have died together early in the morning
Gretel had to go and hang up the core
jhin's of water and light the fire we
will bake first said the old woman I
have already heated the oven and kneaded
the dough she pushed poor Gretel out to
the oven creep in said the witch and see
if it is properly heated so that we may
shut the bread in and once Gretel was
inside she intended to shut the oven and
let her bake in it and then she would
eat her to the Gretel saw what she had
in mind and said I do not know how I am
to do it how do you get in silly goose
said the old woman the door is big
enough just look I can get him myself
and she crept up and thrust her head
into the oven then Gretel gave her a
push that drove her far into it and shut
the I endure and
fasten the bolt she began to howl quite
horribly but Gretel ran away and the
godless witch was miserably burnt to
death
Gretel however ran like lightning to
Hansel opened his stable and cried
Hansel were saved the old witch is dead
then Hansel sprang out like a bird from
a cage when the door was open how they
did rejoice and embrace each other and
dance and kiss each other and as they
had no longer any need to fear her they
went to the witch's house and in every
corner stood chess full of pearls and
jewels these are far better than pebbles
said Hansel and thrust in his pocket
whatever he could get in and Gretel said
I too would take some home with me and
filled her pinafore full but now we will
go away said Hansel that we may get out
of the witch's forest when they had
walked for two hours they came to a
great body of water we cannot get over
said Hansel I seen a foot plank and no
bridge and no boat crosses either
answered Gretel but a white duck is
swimming there if I ask her she will
help us then she cried little duck
little duck
do you see Hansel and Gretel are waiting
for you there's never a plank or bridge
in sight take us across on your back so
white and the duck came to them and
Hansel seated himself on its back and
told his sister to sit by him no replied
Gretel that will be too heavy for the
little duck she shall take us across one
off to the other and the good little
duck did so and when they were safely
across they walked for a short time the
forest seemed to be more familiar to
them and at length they saw from afar
their father's house they began to run
rushed into the parlour and threw
themselves around their father's arms
the man had not known a single happy
hour since he had left his children in
the forest the woman however was dead
Gretel emptied her pinafore until pearls
and precious stones ran about the room
and Hansel threw one handful after
another out of his pocket to enter them
and all anxiety and worry was at an end
and they lived happily together in
perfect
happiness my tail is done see the mouse
run whoever catches it may make himself
a big fur cap out of it and that is a
tale of Hansel and Gretel as told by the
Brothers Grimm
you